you might remember last week I told you
that Lara Logan formerly of 60 minutes
she is a
um uh she is now a right-wing conspiracy
nut I hate to use such uh titillating
and provocative language but that is
what she is she appeared on Newsmax I
played the clip for you she delivered a
completely unhinged xenophobic rant
essentially her version of white
replacement Theory or great replacement
Theory she was banned from Newsmax okay
instead of rethinking some of her ideas
and saying maybe I was wrong on some of
this stuff I don't know
she appeared on the absolute truth on
Lindell TV
with an even crazier conspiracy theory
about children
listen to this
he said I believe that people reacted
that way is it's all about the children
the question they don't want us asking
is where are all the missing children
what happens to these children how can
hundreds of thousands of kids go missing
in the United States every year and
nobody knows where they are they just
vanish I don't think so every sex
trafficking ring worldwide knows bring
the kids to the United States that this
Administration is participating in the
trafficking of kids because they're
paying uh companies llc's and
non-profits and church groups they're
paying them to take these kids and
disappear them including the report that
you showed have talked about the blood
of young children being the secret to
anti-aging you guys are you you know
what she just said right
ingesting or injecting the blood of
young young children as an anti-aging
mechanism
and why does nobody
how do you get the blood of young
children and does it matter if the
children are younger and younger and
younger so now you're told are you
talking about the blood of babies now no
no one's talking about that Lara you
know at this point it genuinely seems
like this is someone who
should be more on the mental health
treatment side than the delivering
opinion publicly side
you got banned from Newsmax Newsmax is
insane and what you said was too crazy
for Newsmax
uh it's time to maybe rethink some of
your views but unfortunately and I'm not
even kidding this is kind of sad because
at one point Lara Logan
did some reasonably good journalistic
reporting
um she is completely off the deep end in
every way and I feel bad for her to some
degree but at the end of the rainbow for
lack of a better term
I want to have compassion and I you know
all these different things at the end of
the rainbow there are so many people in
the United States
so delusional and depraved that even
this stuff they hear and they believe I
mean who would have thought Q Anon
beliefs could invade one-fifth of the
Republican party as we learned in a
recent poll and so my instinct is
empathy and uh you know saying this is
someone who's in in a crisis she needs
support Etc and also extremely dangerous
because of the things that she is saying
which get followers no matter how crazy
they are my friends
subscribe to the YouTube channel we are
doing our very best to get to 2 million
subscribers we're at about 1.55 now we
don't even need any new viewers to get
to 2 million because I learned that last
month
4.3 million different people watched
videos on our YouTube channel and yet
only 1.5 million were subscribers we
already have nearly 3 million additional
viewers they already watch the content
some of them even like it although some
don't if just a fraction of you fine
folks who watch but don't subscribe hit
that subscribe button on YouTube we
could get to 2 million overnight do the
thing youtube.com the davidpackman show
we're going to take maybe the shortest
break in history and be right back with
much more
one of our sponsors is Helix sleep I
have been sleeping on a helix mattress
for years and I always recommend it to
friends you'd simply take this Helix
sleep quiz it asks you about your body
type your sleep position whether you
have back pain and then Helix will match
you up with the mattress that is
personalized to your needs and they ship
it to you for free another reason I went
with Helix is that unlike a lot of
mattress companies out there every
single Helix mattress is made in the USA
by a skilled production team which means
when you buy a helix mattress you're
supporting great jobs I'm not the only
one who loves Helix Helix was recently
awarded number one mattress by both GQ
and Wired Magazine every Helix mattress
comes with a 10 or 15 year warranty you
can try it a hundred nights and send it
back for a full refund if you need to
support the David Pacman show by getting
your next mattress from Helix sleep and
and you'll get up to 350 off any
mattress plus two free pillows when you
go to helixsleep.com Pacman the link is
down below